fortement n'allant pas dans leur sens et
leur condition n'hésitant pas à tordre
les faits et utiliser tous les moyens
pour imposer leur vérité
[Musique]
la communication des modèles macro prêts
à des jeunes via twitter instagram
victhom est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant poule et où ça n'a plus
rien de politique c'est pour se
rapprocher des jeunes mais parce qu'ils
sont beaucoup trop déconnecté de la
sphère politique il pense que ça va
ramener les jeunes à la politique dont
il se désintéresserait en lieu et place
de politiser les jeunes ça dépolitise la
politique pendant la rendant encore plus
qu on est justement c'est une nouvelle
forme de communication assez verticale
utiliser des influenceurs pour moissac
hommes politiques personnelles est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est vraiment
nouveau d'utiliser des célébrités pour
faire de la propagande politique on s'en
fiche nous on veut quelqu'un qui dirige
la france comme si son travail en notre
nom pour nous est dans notre intérêt à
tous
[Musique]
m
très bon soir à tous nous sommes
ensemble comme chaque soir du lundi au
jeudi jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les
grands qui de l'actualité de la journée
n'oubliez pas de réagir sur le
télégramme verte et france vous pourrez
prendre part aux débats et internet
interpeller nos invités au sommaire de
ce lundi 1er novembre six ans près
d'accord de paris sur le climat les
dirigeants du monde entier se donnent
rendez vous au royaume uni objectif de
7,26 à glasgow entériné les commandes
prises en 2015 emmanuel macron appelle
les plus gros émetteurs en retard sur
leur engagement à rehausser leurs
ambitions alors quelles stratégies pour
la france en écosse alors que le bilan
des manuels macron est contestée que
beaucoup pointent du doigt le décalage
entre les beaux discours et les actes
décryptage à suivre dans cette émission
ça serons-nous un hiver sera ou
sera-t-il gâchée par le kobe de 19 en
france augmentation des cas d
hospitalisation
les chiffres font craindre une cinquième
vague sur le plan de la vaccination plus
de 76% des français ont reçu deux doses
une campagne vous le verrez qui n'avance
pas aussi vite surtout chez les
personnes âgées
faut-il interdire la chasse le week-end
c'est la question de notre face à face
ce soir et celle que l'on vous pose on
attend vos réactions à chaud me disais
sur le conte télégramme rt france un
sujet qui alimente le débat politique à
six mois de la présidentielle après deux
accidents de chasse ces derniers jours
certains défenseurs de la cause animale
soutenus par des élus veulent
l'interdire les scènes du dimanche hors
de question pour les chasseurs qui a
notamment de leurs efforts en matière de
sécurité
nous irons à la rencontre de l'un
d'entre dès 21h pour notre rubrique en
pensent les français ce soir
[Musique]
la montagne coop 20,6 accouchera-t-elle
d'une souris la conférence climat à la
plus importante depuis la cap 21 et la
signature de l'accord de paris en 2015
se tient à glasgow en écosse un rendez
vous pris pao pour 15 jours par les
dirigeants des quatre coins du monde
pour tenter de sauver la planète on en
parle avec elle notre reporter david
kelly favon soir david des dizaines de
chefs d'état ont pris la parole
aujourd'hui à glasgow que retenir de ces
discours et notamment de celui d'
emmanuel macron
et bien ses fans il ya d'abord eu celui
de joe biden le président américain
s'est montré très inquiet sur la
situation et souhaite avant tout
apporter son soutien aux pays en voie de
développement le discours là des ménages
macro est arrivé un peu plus tard un
discours très attendu attendu au
tournant pour cette coop 26 un temps le
bilan du chef d'état le bilan écologique
est très critiqué sur le plan national
le président français souhaite s'imposer
sur le plan international alors
plusieurs choses à retenir d'abord le
défi que constitue la mise en oeuvre des
objectifs de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre malgré plusieurs
lois sur le sujet la france peine pour
le moment à respecter les objectifs
fixés emmanuel macron insistait
également sur le fait que les accords
commerciaux doivent refléter les
engagements climatiques de chacun des
pays et coûté les deux présidents
nous devons aider les pays en
développement nous devons agir comme
partenaire aujourd'hui
nous sommes encore loin du compte
nous devons conjuguer nos efforts il
faut écouter l'appel de l'histoire ici à
glasgow marcon le point de départ
d'actions qui vont améliorer la qualité
de vie de chacun sur cette planète nous
en sommes capables mais nous devons
faire le choix trop d'entre nous
prennent ici des engagements et ensuite
signent des accords commerciaux qui font
exactement le contraire nous nous
tournons nous pouvons plus continuer à
avoir une planète qu'on fait fonctionner
selon une grammaire et des règles qui
n'intègre pas en son coeur en son coeur
ses contraintes nos accords commerciaux
doivent refléter nos engagements
climatiques
l'organisation de nos chaînes de valeur
doivent refléter nos exigences
climatiques vers l'inde ou bien encore
les états unis mais la france peut y
faire un bonne place également puisque
c'est précisément le reproche fait par
l'opposition au président lors de la
signature du traité de libre-échange
avec le canada un discours pavé à de
bonnes intentions mais difficilement
crédible pour les ong et associations
qui ont manifesté aux abords de la coop
26 et david la russie n'a pas fait le
déplacement mais a tenu à envoyer un
message pour la planète
effectivement et stéphanie c'est un
véritable changement de cap pour la
russie longtemps considéré comme
climato-sceptiques par l'union
européenne le discours a changé vladimir
poutine s'est montré préoccupé par le
réchauffement climatique
à tel point que le chef de l'état a fixé
un objectif la neutralité carbone du
pays au plus tard en 2060 à dimitri
peskov le porte parole du kremlin
réaffirmé cette position écouter
je ne peux pas parler pour la chine ou
l'arabie saoudite
mais la russie a participé très
activement au travail du g20
j'ai cité les chefs de notre délégation
il ne faut pas oublier les discours très
instructif du président poutine lui bien
que ce fût en visioconférence en ce qui
concerne le cap sur la transition vers
la note lité carbone il faut garder à
l'esprit que cette ligne directrice a
été tracée par la russie dès 2010 c'est
très important cela était déclarée par
le président et cette déclaration n'a
pas été faite au sommet du g20 mais
quelques jours plus tôt voire quelques
semaines plus tôt
voilà des engagements qui seront suivies
avec beaucoup d'attention pour rappel la
côte 26 doit maintenir en vie l'espoir
d'une limitation de la hausse de la
température mondiale à 1,5 degré celsius
par rapport à la période préindustrielle
après les discours inauguraux qui vont
s'étaler sur les deux premiers jours les
experts entreront dans le vif du sujet
dès mercredi et tenteront de parvenir à
un accord d'ici la fermeture de la coop
26 le 12 novembre prochain ou même après
merci beaucoup david kelly fab pour ce
résumé complet de la journée des
discours des chefs d'état y mène mâcon
qui appelle donc à retrouver l'esprit de
l'accord de paris mais quel bilan
écologistes pour le chef d'état français
depuis son fameux discours qui lui a
valu le titre de champion de la terre
par l'onu en 2018 c'est l'heure de notre
décryptage
[Musique]
pour en parler ce soir charles de la con
membres du conseil fédéral des amis de
la terre en direct avec nous bonsoir
kevin goût et analyste en stratégie
environnementale cofondateur de
l'association ans de bruyne global
project bonsoir et merci à vous d'être
re en direct avec nous sur ce plateau
pour la partie un peu plus
internationale puisque évidemment c'est
toute la planète qui est représenté
régis le sommier grand reporter rt
france bonsoir régissent le succès de
l'accord 26 est à portée de main a dit
emmanuel macron si nous nous mobilisons
décidons et agissons à la portée de main
vraiment c'est aussi simple que ça le
passé nous l'a pas franchement démontrer
régis non puisque déjà on sait ce qui
s'est passé donc là les accords de paris
les etats unis se sont retirés avec
fracas on s'en souvient c'était le
premier acte du gouvernement trompe de
sortir de ce cadre il y avait déjà des
commandes et des objectifs qui sont un
peu similaires qui avaient été fixés au
moment de la coop 21 et au moment de la
commentaires il y avait une sorte d'
enthousiasme à lorsqu on note
aujourd'hui c'est que un certain nombre
de leaders internationaux joe biden
emmanuel macron essaye de le re suscité
cet enthousiasme emmanuel macron je
pense je joue une partition du bon élève
de la classe dans l'âme dans la mesure
où la france n'est qu'au 12e rang des
pays les plus pollueurs du monde et que
le nucléaire lui a permis justement
d'éviter des maîtres du dixie dioxyde de
carbone comme la plupart des grands pays
industriels donc la france a choisi une
politique énergétique différentes et qui
la met un petit peu à l'abri je dirais
de deux de ses critiques donc emmanuel
macron essaye aujourd'hui d'apparaître
un leader dans cette en ce domaine alors
qu'on le sait au niveau du g20 ça n'a
pas été tout à fait comment la grande
réconciliation avec les états unis et
emmanuel macron justement et c est
apparu comme un peu je dirai comment
toujours humilié et la france toujours
humilié par le parent par le géant
américain
lancé en réponse à donald trump a un qui
avait décidé vous l'avez dit régis de
quitter la corde de paris c'est resté
dans la mémoire y compris à l'étranger
mais emmanuel macron en france on est
très critiquée par les écologistes
charles de lacombe vous attendez tout de
même quelque chose du président français
pour ce nouveau rendez-vous
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est difficile
de dire qu'on attend encore vraiment
quelque chose de lui dans son discours
tout à l'heure je les regarde et il a
parlé d' ambition alors que lui la seule
qu'il a pour le climat c'est de jeter
toujours plus de technologie pour
essayer de résoudre le problème il a
parlé de solidarité alors que finalement
les mesures sont toujours pas prises
pour accompagner les pays du sud qui
sont les plus exposés au dérèglement
climatique par notre faute finalement
aura tout l'été les pays occidentaux du
nord l'union européenne la russie les
etats-unis ont une grosse dette
climatique vis-à-vis de ces pays là et
ne font rien concrètement aujourd'hui
pour les aider il ya eu beaucoup de
critiques à l'égard de la com 26
d'ailleurs puisque c'est aussi des pays
qui sont très touchés par le cos vide
qui ont difficilement pu s'organiser
pour venir participer bref et enfin il a
parlé de confiance il a dit qu'il
fallait rétablir la confiance avec les
citoyens à faire plus de transparence et
c'est difficile de dire ça depuis sa
position alors que ça fait quatre ans
lui qu'il est à la tête de l'état un des
principaux année une des principales
puissances du g20 et qui m'a fait
l'inversé de ce qu'il a dit en fait tout
ce qu'il y avait dans son discours était
vrai et et wii était vraiment l' inverse
de ce qu'il a fait pendant ces quatre
ans à la tête de la france alors il a
été quand même ambitieux ans il a appelé
notamment à plus d'engagement pour
revenir aux 1,5 degré comme espéré lors
de l'accord de paris dont il veut
retrouver l'esprit at il dit mais c'est
vrai que la france un souvent kevin
boyer est critiqué pour faire pression
pour que le gaz est nucléaire soit soit
propre c'est pas vraiment le choix des
écologistes
non il faut savoir que si l'on peut
parler vraiment d'énergie
il faut comprendre que le nucléaire
c'est entre guillemets l'énergie qui
nous permet de décarbonée notre
système économique actuel
par contre le nucléaire n'est pas une
solution écologique et le gaz c'est très
émetteurs de co2 le pétrole encore plus
et le charbon encore plus qui est à la
principale source de production
électrique en france en parlant de
france dans le monde excuser pour ce
faire
il est important de comprendre quels
sont les enjeux qui sont les nôtres
beaucoup de monde parle de climat il est
essentiel de comprendre qu'il n'ya pas
que des enjeux de climat il ya aussi des
enjeux liés à la de diversité la
première
cause de l'est la sixième extinction
masse de l'activité une aide et ça
arrive rien à voir avec les différents
enjeux climatiques
on le voit notamment que par exemple la
surpêche craie qui lie à une disparition
des coraux qui a une disparition de la
plupart des espèces comme les dauphins
et les baleines et plein d'autres noms
du poisson et des petites espèces qui
sont présentes partout
moi quand j'entends par là qu on mélange
un petit peu tous leurs deux de ces
coques 26 et que c'est pas vraiment
lisible c'est exactement ça et pour
avoir pu participer à lille c'est elle
qui est l'équivalent de la coop mais
version biodiversité
il faut bien comprendre que quand
on va retrouver kevin goût et dans
quelques instants la connexion est en
mauvaise régis le sommier vous parliez
tout à l'heure vous évoquiez joe biden
rapidement le président américain qui
s'est excusé on l'a vu auprès des
dirigeants pour le retrait des états
unis de l'accord de paris il a qualifié
la lutte contre le réchauffement
d'opportunités incroyable pour
l'économie mondiale tout va changer avec
le sauveur baydan donc pas du tout là on
est en cours dont dans une forme
d'hypocrisie puisque les américains sont
les principaux pollueurs mondiaux la
chine arrive derrière donc les
américains émettent environ 20% du
dioxyde de carbone dans l'atmosphère la
chine est à 11 la russie et l'inde
étaient juste après la russie entend
ensuite viennent viennent ensuite le
brésil et quelques autres pays comme
l'indonésie mais donc là la grande
hypocrisie des aides des états unis
c'est de dire effectivement on va miser
sur des technologies nouvelles ce que
tout le discours de buydens y revenez à
dire finalement que on allait créer des
emplois en ayant une attitude
écologistes en ayant en transformant
finalement l'industrie et que les états
unis allaient y arriver certes ils ont
les capacités technologiques on sait
qu'ils sont très en avance là-dessus
mais néanmoins les états unis restent
encore un pays dont
25% ou entre 20 et 25% de l'électricité
est produite par le charbon c'est des
deux ans aux états unis vous avez encore
des accidents de grisou comme en pologne
jeudi on est dans ce genre de vous allez
dans les alpes dans les appalaches vous
avez encore ce type de mine donc les
états unis dire oui on va comment tout
s'y mettre et on va arriver à ce comment
ce but de 1,5 degré à la fin du siècle
lui signale qu entre parenthèses une
étude des nations unies de septembre
place plutôt l'augmentation le
réchauffement climatique à 2,7 degrés et
on est loin des 1,5 annoncé par emmanuel
macron donc je veux dire la grande
transformation que nous promet byden de
l'industrie américaine va prendre
énormément de temps et encore une fois
c'est le principal pollueur au monde
aujourd'hui charles de vacants quand on
entend effectivement emmanuel macron
nous dire yaka il suffit de si on est
mobilisé si on prend l'est
les décisions qui s'imposent sauf que là
comme vient nous le rappelle régis le
sommier il est sur une ambition de 5
degrés alors que l'onu comme vous l'avez
dit un parent d'un réchauffement
catastrophique de 2,7 degrés à la fin du
siècle
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire pour y
arriver parce que tous les toutes les
critiques voilà on l'air de dire que
tout les coptes qui s'enchaînent ne
donne jamais eu beaucoup de résultats
pardon
pour clarifier
le 1,5 degré c'est l'objectif qui a été
acté dans les accords de paris c'est le
seuil à ne pas dépasser et si on
n'arrive pas à ne pas dépasser les 1,5
degré c'est ne pas dépasser les 2 degrés
et si on fait la somme des engagements
qui ont été pris par les états pour
respecter l'accord de paris c'est là où
on arrive actuellement à plus de tables
7° dont déjà on a des des objectifs des
engagements qui sont insuffisants et en
plus les états en fait ne respectent pas
leurs engagements et la france pas plus
que les autres ce qui fait que on est
parti même pour dépasser ses plus de 7
degrés d'ici la fin du siècle dont
classés c'est quand même quelque chose
qui est assez catastrophique là dessus
ça veut pas dire que le processus des
coques est inutile et qu'il faudrait pas
le faire puisque la crise climatique
c'est un problème global qui appelle
évidemment une réponse globale mais
simplement sondés sont des processus qui
ne sont pas un qui ne permettent pas qui
ne sont pas contraignants qui ne permet
pas d'obtenir des garanties fortes de la
part des états et c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on a qu'on a besoin d'une
mobilisation citoyenne très forte c'est
pour ça que la moire aujourd'hui où elle
est née kelly la qualité un petit peu
déplorable de la vidéo c'est parce que
je suis dans les rues de glasgow ce
matin je sais une action citoyenne avec
le collectif action non violente comme
21 pour dénoncer le double discours des
dirigeants est particulièrement emmanuel
macron pour montrer que la société
civile et mobiliser la société civile
n'est pas dupe des mensonges elle voit
que macro et parc emmanuel macron est un
pompier pyromane et on est là pour
mettre la pression pour forcer les états
à respecter leurs engagements
concrètement puisque l'on parle de nos
conditions d'existence tout simplement
kevin goûts et pour vous partager ce
diagnostic parce que c'est ce qui
revient souvent aussi une forme
d'hypocrisie
2 et de double discours de la part des
dirigeants et notamment celui d'ailleurs
d'emmanuel macron
je le partage totalement et j'aimais
j'irai même plus loin un exemple concret
qui montre cette hypocrisie
c'est la convention citoyenne pour le
climat moi je travaille au quotidien
avec les 150 citoyenne la convention
citoyenne qu'on fait un travail mais
hors norme et
malgré le maquereau hors mis à part
avoir fait de l'acquisition politique
avec ses 140 propositions il n'y aurait
sorti une loi climat qui n'est pas loin
climat qui est une loi
pour faire beau voilà tout simplement
kinois qui est là pour faire faire beau
dans le paysage politique et pour dire
oui moi monsieur emmanuel macron je
répond aux enjeux climatiques
pour avoir parlé avec le maire et
emmanuel macron partage exactement le
même principe
il n'ya pas longtemps leurs demis
transition forum j'ai pu voir avec eux
quelle est l'essence même de qu'ailleurs
vision visé l'environnement pour
l'environnement c'est un problème et ce
au problème ils le traitent en dix ans
la technologie c'est ça qui sauvera le
monde il faut savoir que les grandes
entreprises comme veolia total à
l'énergie et c'est
la même vision
emmanuel macron n'est autre qu'un
entrepreneur
d'une nation dirige une nation qu'elle
c'était une entreprise on ne peut pas
diriger une nation comme ça une
entreprise et les intrus qui est
essentielle et que je voulais dire tout
à l'heure avant que s'aveuglent désolé
pour betclic
emmanuel par macro on parle d'écologie
je vous invite vous médias a interrogé
emmanuel macron sur ce qu'est l'écologie
il ne sera même pas définir concrètement
ces martyrs n'a pas assez mignonne macro
qui vous donne pas d'accréditation pour
aller on lui parlait donc régis le
sommier sur 7 sur cette hypocrisie c'est
rigolo parce que ils sont pas tous venus
en bateau à voile c'est cher dirigeant à
glasgow surtout autour d'eux des des
dirigeants il ya un certain nombre de
milices de ce qu'on peut appeler les
milliardaires vert c'est-à-dire des jeff
des os et autres qui sont eux arrivés
avec leur jet privé un des os a pris son
golf stream voilà flambant neuf et alors
ce qui est intéressant parce que la
presse anglaise évidemment s'est emparé
de cette histoire puisqu'il ya environ
400 avions privés 400 jet privé qui sont
arrivés oui ça fait beaucoup et pour la
alors j'ai noté c'est le daily mail qui
publie sa pour la journée d'hier plein
seule journée d'hier l'aéroport de
glasgow a été donc accueilli 52 jet
privé et ça émis dans l'atmosphère 13000
tonnes de dioxyde de carbone soit
l'équivalent de ce qu'émettent 1600
anglais en un an voilà ils vont faire
une petite comparaison pour montrer que
ces gens effectivement ben 400 avions
privés pour venir à une coop on est on
essaye justement de réduire des
émissions de gaz et de bon voilà et on
alors bon il le prince charles également
utilisé un jet à rubis s'est il a dit
oui mais j'utilise un carburant du rap
d'aviation qui respecte et cetera et
cetera le prince albert aussi à utiliser
son jet privé ces gens là pourrait
peut-être déjà voyager sur des vols
commerciaux et on sait aussi qu'un
certain nombre de délégués
malheureusement de moins nantis sont
restés en rade et n'ont pas pu venir
parce qu'il ya eu des intempéries le pr
pensé prendre le train donc un moyen de
transport nettement moins polluants
voilà
l'état français charles de la combat qui
a on le rappelle aussi le mois dernier
été condamnés dans le cadre de la sphère
du siècle on rappelle pour ceux qui
avaient oublié quatre organisations
d'intérêt général qui ont assigné l'état
français en justice devant le tribunal
administratif de paris pour inaction
face au changement climatique donc et un
français condamné
c'est là encore le double discours que
l'on voit aujourd'hui à glasgow
oui absolument donc effectivement vous
faites bien de mentionner il ya eu cette
condamnation par le tribunal
administratif
il ya également eu une autre
condamnation un peu plus tôt dans
l'année par le conseil d'état cette fois
suite à un recours de l'acompte de la
commune de grande synthe pour nom
protection de l'état reste mon
protection des habitants et des français
face au climat tic encore une autre
condamnation du conseil d'état pour
inaction face à la pollution de l'air
donc effectivement on est sur un an on
est sur un état qui est condamné trois
fois par les paras part des plus hautes
instances de la république française
c'est assez assez terrible et pour pour
revenir sur ce qu'on disait de soleure
et pour aller plus loin effectivement on
l'a on est plus sur deux de l'inaction
on est sur un véritable sabotage
climatique en fait puisque non seulement
il
ya le l'inaction et le
qui devrait faire des peines n'est pas
celle ci devrait être fait n'est pas
fait mais on a des discours qui sont
lénifiant en dormant qui empêche de
bouger qui font croire que la france est
leader etc et en plus il ya un soutien
absolument délétère had à des
entreprises vous avez mentionné jeff
bezos amazon par exemple c'est une
entreprise qui est largement soutenue
par emmanuel macron dans le cadre de la
loi climat avec les amis de la terre on
a on a failli faire passer on avait
convaincu plein de député de la
république en marge de faire passer des
mesures pour endiguer l'expansion
d'amazones qui non seulement détruit des
emplois mais en plus cause de la de la
surconsommation et de la surproduction
ce qui n'est pas du tout cohérent avec
des trajectoires qu'on devrait avoir
emmanuel macron c'est également des
soutiens sans faille à total par exemple
qui a des projets extrêmement
problématique de palpable de pipeline à
la fois en ouganda à la fois en arctique
donc voilà c'est vraiment cette notion
de sabotage et il ne fait pas il dit
qu'il fait et en même temps il fait l
inverse de ce qu il faudrait faire un
dernier mot registre classe ce
décryptage évidemment l'absence très
commenté et critiqué de la chine et de
la russie en tout cas sur place à
glasgow oui absence mais qui est donc à
chaque fois justifié dans un cas comme
dans l'autre puisque guide épines on le
sait nage ne s'est pas déplacé tout
depuis de chine depuis
l'année dernière depuis le début de la
pandémie donc ça y est une raison et une
résurgence justement du coc vide en
chine donc c'est l'explication qui a été
donné on sait qu'il a suivie par
visioconférence le g20 tout en envoyant
xics et son ministre des affaires
étrangères parlées et comment justement
là sur les d d'autres affaires
internationales avec ses partenaires la
sur la question la russie il n'y a pas
vraiment d'explication c'est simplement
que le porte parole du kremlin dimitri
peskov lui a exprimé clairement que la
russie s'était engagé à réduire ses
émissions de dioxyde de carbone d'ici
2050 de 80% et également à abandonner
progressivement le charbon au profit du
nucléaire donc la russie montre qu'elle
est là pendant la coop 21 l'époque de la
coop 21 vladimir poutine avait elle fait
le déplacement à paris pour ce sommet du
climat merci résistance aux mille merci
également à vous charles de lacombe et
kevin agout et d'avoir été en direct sur
rt france et pour interpeller les
dirigeants qui participent à cette coque
26 des manifestations pro clima on en
parlait avec charles de la comba sont
organisées aussi à travers le monde à
glasgow rome ou encore new york est les
protestataires demandent aux grandes
puissances plus d'actions concrètes en
matière de nos vies ronnement à tour
d'horizon avec amaya sauver
des solutions concrètes en faveur du
climat ce sont les raisons de nombreuses
manifestations à travers le monde alors
que la coop 26 a débuté ce lundi
des rues envahies de banderoles et de
pancartes tout en faveur d'une action
concrète pour l'environnement
je pense que si nous descendons dans la
rue avec toutes ces sortes de personnes
pas seulement ici mais dans le monde
entier je pense qu'à un moment donné ils
devront nous écouter parce que la
situation n'est plus possible de cette
façon
la coop 26 réuni de nombreux chefs
d'état à travers le monde l'occasion
pour les pros climat de faire entendre
leurs revendications
à glasgow où se tient la conférence des
militants de l'organisation oxfam ont
revêtu des masques de dirigeants
politiques et exhorte les gouvernements
à agir
nous avons besoin de financement
climatique les pays pauvres ont besoin
de financements climatiques les
communautés vulnérables ont besoin de
financement climatique et ils doivent
être sérieux à ce sujet pour soutenir
les pays vulnérables pour s'adapter aux
pires impacts de la crise climatique en
allemagne le son de cloche est identique
des milliers de militants se sont
rassemblés à l'outré rate contre
l'expansion d'une mine à ciel ouvert
dénonçant un débat sans issue
aujourd'hui alors que nous bloquons la
mine à ciel ouvert de 15 valeurs ici à
glasgow commence la coop 26 cela
signifie qu'il ya eu un débat pendant
trente ans sans réelle action les faits
concernant la crise climatique sont sur
la table depuis les années 50 mais le
gouvernement continue à protéger les
intérêts du profit et à les faire passer
avant la vie des gens mêmes
revendications aux états unis
à new york des manifestants ont défilé
devant le siège de citibank pour
dénoncer une politique environnementale
qu'il juge mortifère le g20 qui s'est
tenu ce week end à rome a également mené
à des manifestations contre la crise
climatique dans l'espoir d' actions
durables et concrète d'un meilleur futur
pour les années à venir
pour les chefs d'état réunis à glasgow
c'est l'occasion rêvée de répondre aux
attentes d'une opinion publique
désormais unanimement soucieuse de
conserver une planète viable
et inondations sécheresses ou encore un
sens lille les phénomènes météo extrêmes
se multiplient un bilan alarmiste en
2021 mis en lumière dans un nouveau
rapport de l'organisation météorologique
mondiale
l'étude provisoire de l'organisation
météorologique mondiale sur l'état du
climat en 2021 rapporte que les sept
dernières années sont probablement les
plus chaudes jamais enregistrées en juin
juillet dernier des vagues de chaleurs
exceptionnelles ont touché le canada
dans de nombreuses villes les valeurs
records des stations été dépassé de 4 à
6 degrés celsius cette vague de chaleur
a entraîné des centaines de décès des
records de chaleur ont également été
battus en italie en turquie ou encore en
tunisie cet été le dixie fire le plus
grand incendie jamais enregistré en
californie s'est déclaré le 13 juillet
lors du dernier bilan effectué le 7
octobre
390 mille hectares avaient été détruits
de grands feux incontrôlés se sont
également déclarés dont de nombreuses
régions de la méditerranée l'algérie le
sud de la turquie et la grèce ont été
particulièrement touchés les 14 et 15
juillet entre 100 et 150 mm de pluie
sont tombés sur l'ouest de l'allemagne
et l'est de la belgique provoquant des
inondations et des glissements de
terrain qui ont coûté la vie à plus de
200 personnes les crues ont également
frappé certaines régions d'afrique de
l'est le sud du soudan a été très
durement touchée au début du mois de
septembre
au contraire une grave sécheresse a
touché une grande partie de l'amérique
du sud pour la deuxième année
consécutive
provoquant d'importantes pertes dans les
récoltes une importante sécheresse a
également touché madagascar ce qui a
entraîné une grave crise alimentaire
dans ses conclusions l'organisation
météorologique mondiale c'est le lien
entre ces phénomènes météorologiques et
le dérèglement climatique
selon l'analyse de la vague de chaleur
du pacifique nord ouest ce phénomène
reste rare ou très rare dans le climat
actuel mais il aurait été pratiquement
impossible sans le changement climatique
pour ce qui est des inondations en
europe occidentale il a été établi que
le changement climatique a augmenté la
probabilité des fortes précipitations
présent à glasgow pour la coop 26 p
terry dallas secrétaire général de
l'organisation météorologique mondiale
alerte et les dirigeants internationaux
et souhaite qu'ils s'engagent à
respecter les objectifs des accords de
paris
il faut que sa présence sur une des
régions du monde tout particulièrement
menacées par le réchauffement climatique
la step de kalmoukie au sud de la russie
l'unique région bouddhistes d'europe il
se transforme inexorablement en désert à
grazailles à le premier dr d'europe
c'est ainsi qu'est nommé la step de la
république de kalmoukie dans le sud de
la russie des paysages qui ressemble à
s'y méprendre au désert du sahara chaque
été se vêtent l'anah bozza eva va
inspecter les dégâts causés par le
changement climatique
avant il y avait de vastes étendues de
sable ici maintenant les arbustes qui
ont été plantés ont fait leur travail
ils ont arrêter l'avancée des sables
sinon ce phénomène aurait totalement
recouvert le village de bergin de sable
en quelques années
on peut dire que nous l'avons sauver de
l'ensablement
ces plantations ont permis d'arrêter une
dune qui menacent et d'enveloppés la
ville dans cette région si l'élevage
bovin est un pilier traditionnel de
l'économie locale il est également une
cause de la fragilisation du sol en les
piétinant le bétail contre empêcher les
plans de s'enraciner à cela s'ajoute un
surpâturage qui accentue le phénomène de
désertification
mais le responsable principal de la
situation est tout désigné le
réchauffement climatique
tout d'abord les températures change
cela ne fait aucun doute la quantité de
précipitations a chuté de manière
drastique et s'il y a des plus en état
elles sont cohérentes et leur
évaporation très rapide et dany boon
mais moi l'autre il
pour les habitants le souvenir le plus
marquant est celui de l'été 2020 avec
des milliers d'animaux tombé mort à
travers la steppe en raison d'un manque
de nourriture consécutifs à des mois
sans la moindre pluie
c est horrible de voir ce bétail les
animaux chercher de l'herbe mais il n'y
en avait pas du tout quand on roulait
dans la steppe on voyait des cadavres de
chevaux de vaches de chameau un peu
partout
c'était vraiment effrayant
nous ressentions de la pitié pour les
animaux
pour venir en aide aux éleveurs le
gouvernement a annoncé l'état d'urgence
et obtenu l'équivalent de 7,9 millions
de dollars du gouvernement fédéral
nous réfléchissons constamment au
changement climatique
si nous considérons l'agriculture dans
son ensemble avec le travail effectué
par le ministère nous nous consacrons
tous à atténuer les conséquences de ces
situations d'urgence comme celle qui
s'est produite ici en 2020
se concentrer sur les effets du
changement climatique plutôt que sur ses
causes profondes c'est le choix fait par
le gouvernement
mais le mois dernier une stratégie de
décarbonisation plus intense a été
lancée avec un objectif de zéro
émissions nettes de carbone d'ici à 2060
en attendant les principaux ennemis
demeure le sable le vent et des
températures anormalement élevées
deux semaines de rendez vous donnez donc
en écosse pour entériner les promesses
prises en 2015 coup projecteurs ce soir
sur le pays hôte avec nous claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales
bonsoir claude blanchemaison merci à toi
d'être avec nous les générations futures
qui nous pardonneront pas si nous
échouons cette rave elle est signée
boris johnson inquiété très remonté
aujourd'hui le premier ministre
britannique il faut dire que la coop
présente des enjeux importants pour son
pays pour lui même moi je crois qu'il
aimerait bien avoir un succès
diplomatique c'est une réunion en effet
très importante avec beaucoup de noms de
des hommes politiques mais aussi les ong
mais aussi des spécialistes et il
voudrait à un succès politique
franchement il aura un petit peu de mal
à avoir un succès politique parce que
l'objectif de cette coop 26 et d'essayer
de modifier de corriger la trajectoire
sur laquelle nous sommes qui roule yeux
nous emmener vers une limite d'une
hausse de température de 1 5% à
l'échéance fixée par la coop 21 à paris
et nous emmène plus tôt vers le double
en tout cas vers 2,7 ou 2,8
degrés pas pourcentage pardon degrés est
évidemment pour pour éviter cela pour se
remettre sur la trajectoire de 1,5 degré
il faudrait que chaque participant
chaque état prenne des engagements très
forts et ne semble pas que ce soit
vraiment le cas donc boris johnson va
avoir beaucoup de mal à obtenir ce
succès et bien sûr il a utilisé un
langage dramatique vous avez cité
certains de ses propos il a même il a
même cité
l'écologiste la jeune suédoise que l'on
voit surtout les sur toutes les
télévisions en disant pas de bla bla bla
pas de bla bla bla c'est qu'elle vit
c'est ce qu'elle dit habituellement nous
voulons des décisions concrètes et qui
produisent des effets simplement je
pense que ça va être très difficile bien
même si la grande bretagne et les pays
européens sont prêts à annoncer des
efforts supplémentaires alors justement
pas de blabla est-ce que ça concerne le
royaume-uni est ce que c'est un bon
élève par rapport au reste du monde pour
le charbon oui pour l'hydrocarbure non
le charbon oui alors c'est assez
intéressant parce que dans le fond la
révolution industrielle a eu lieu au
départ au royaume uni avec le charbon la
machine à vapeur le charbon et le
royaume uni a réussi à adekar boon et
son économie
il y a encore dix ans le charbon
représentaient 40% de la production
électrique est aujourd'hui c'est quelque
chose comme 2 % et ce sera fini il y
aura plus de centrales à charbon pour
faire de l'électricité dans deux ans
donc c'est une réussite de ce point de
vue là mais en revanche le gouvenement
de britanniques continuent de donner des
licences d'exploration pétrolière au
large et ville shetland donc offshore et
ceci commence à déranger un peu madame
soeur jeunes c'est-à-dire la cheffe du
gouvernement écossais qui considère que
pour donner de nouvelles licences de
recherche d'hydrocarbures ou
d'exploitation d'hydrocarbures a
fortiori il devrait consulter le
gouvernement écossais ce qu'il ne fait
pas en effet c'est de la compétence de
londres alors par ailleurs le nucléaire
représente environ 20% et des centrales
nucléaires sont en construction y
compris des centrales de technologie
français d'ailleurs donc
disons comparons ce qui est comparable
c'est-à-dire les pays de l' ocde des
pays développés et la grande bretagne le
royaume et grande bretagne se situe
pratiquement au milieu des pays de l'
ocde dans le palmarès de la lutte contre
les émissions de co2 en tout cas le
gouvernement johnson qui veut atteindre
la neutralité carbone en 2050 également
vous restez avec nous si vous le voulez
bien que blanche maison pour évoquer un
tout autre sujet avec cette délicate
question de la pêche post break site 1
qui justement poison un petit peu les
relations des deux pays les discussions
d'ailleurs se poursuivront demain entre
la france et londres selon des
déclarations ce soir d' emmanuel macron
le temps presse puisque la france est
prête à interdire dès demain un navire
britannique de débarquer dans ces ports
londres appelle à aujourd'hui paria
retirer ses menaces valérie la bonne
ils se sont enfin de parler boris
johnson emmanuel macron se sont
entretenu une trentaine de minutes
dimanche en marge du sommet du g20 une
discussion à huis clos pour trouver des
solutions au conflit qui les oppose
depuis des mois sur les licences de
pêche mais à l'issue de l'entretien le
bilan des deux dirigeants n'est pas le
même alors que le président français
communique en premier sur l'adoption de
mesures pratiques dans les prochains
jours et parle d'une désescalade son
homologue britannique conteste fermement
le compte-rendu français comme fish en
ce qui concerne la pêche je vais vous
répondre que notre position est
inchangée
je dirai juste pour le compte rendu
que je suis perplexe de l'île
demandant explicitement que la grande
bretagne soit puni pour avoir quitté
l'union européenne
et je ne crois pas que cela soit
compatible avec l'esprit et la lettre de
l'accord
côté français paris réclame que toutes
les demandes de licence faite par les
pêcheurs tricolores soient satisfaites
et propose une méthode pour sortir de ce
conflit sans quoi les mesures de
rétorsion prévues pour le 2 novembre
seront maintenus celle ci prévoit des
contrôles douaniers renforcés et
l'interdiction pour les bateaux anglais
de débarquer leur cargaison dans les
ports français ça ce que j'appelle la
désescalade et c'est ce que nous avons
dit en tête à tête tout à l'heure nous
avons remis aux équipes du président du
premier ministre johnson pardon document
actant de cette méthode
maintenant la balle est dans leur camp
si les britanniques ne font aucun
mouvement de manière évidente les
mesures qui sont prévues à partir du 2
novembre devront se mettre en place
parce que ce sera une fin de non
recevoir la balle est dans le camp des
britanniques les deux pays invoque le
respect des accords signés entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni au moment
du bric site et appelle tout de
bruxelles à jouer les juges de paix
alors qu'ils sont loin de s'entendre sur
la méthode la désescalade semble encore
être un mirage surtout pour les
principaux intéressés les pêcheurs
français et britanniques qui aspire à
naviguer dans des eaux plus tranquille
c'est toujours nous sommes toujours avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales effectivement cette
crispation sur sur la pêche on va voir
ces images tout à l'heure des manuels
mais crouy et boris johnson qui se
saluent à la coop
26 c'est une séquence forte de ce rendez
vous regardez petit sourire quand même
un peu crispé il faut dire que comme on
l'a entendu dans ce sujet il ya quelques
petits ultimatum en cours en ce moment
notamment entre entre les deux hommes
même si voilà on la joue une bonne
figure de façade en tout cas aujourd'hui
à glasgow
claude oui en réalité ce qui se passe
actuellement on sait qu'on se bat à
coups de grands principes chaque que
chaque parti dit il faut respecter le
traité et il faut par conséquent les
français disent on veut de licences de
200 licences supplémentaires et les
britanniques disent mais on a accordé
tout ce qu'on devait accorder contenu
les critères fixés en réalité l'enjeu
réel du débat il est très technique
comme ça arrive parfois et on avancera
rien tant qu'on se battra à coup de
grands principes c'est bon un bon signe
qui est des négociations qui continue
demain j'espère qu'elles sont entre
techniciens parce qu'en réalité le sujet
qui est en débat c'est de savoir si les
pêcheurs artisanaux s'étaient avec des
petits bateaux normands et bretons ont
la possibilité de continuer à pêcher
l'habitude de pêcher ou leur grand-père
avait aussi l'habitude de pêcher autour
de jersey ça s'appelle des zones
traditionnelles de pêche mais ce que
réclament les anglais et les autorités
de jersey qui sont un peu autonome par
rapport à lons une dans une tradition du
grand duché de normandie eh bien ce sont
des preuves que ces pêcheurs normands et
bretons péché bien dans cet endroit là
ya dix ans il ya 15 ans comme ce sont
des petits bateaux de pêche qui n'ont
pas l'équipement électronique qui permet
de le démontrer ils ont des carnets de
bord basse bien entendu avec un crayon
de papier et un crayon bic et
ea carnet de bord ça ne peut pas faire
fois puisqu'on peut en fabriquer un tous
les jours donc c'est ça l'objet de la
discussion
et si on enferme les gens de bonne foi
je pense qu'on peut trouver une solution
une solution technique c'est à dire que
il suffit d'interroger les gens de
jersey et les pêcheurs dans les ports
concernés en normandie henry henry en
bretagne et on verra bien s'ils disent
la vérité lorsqu'ils disent qu'ils sont
des pêcheurs traditionnels dans les
autres jersey parce que tout le monde le
sait effectivement mais ça ne peut pas
relever de grands principes et puis il
ya aussi un mystère qui est que en 2000
on avait négocié une convention pour
justement fixé ces pratiques ancestrales
et cette convention bilatérale entre la
france jersey et le royaume uni n'a pas
été reprise dans les traités du bric
site peut-être parce qu'un juriste
français ou un juriste britannique
trouvais que ça faisait mauvais effet
dans un arbre etc site pure et dure et
bien car et c'est dommage parce que si
on avait repris cette convention et bien
il y aurait pas de problème puisque tout
le monde était satisfait à jersey comme
sur les côtes normandes et bretonnes sur
cet arrangement encore une fois pour les
bateaux artisanaux pas pour les gros
bateaux industriels naturellement merci
en tout cas qu'à blanche les ans nous
avoir apporté votre votre éclairage
moscou rond traditionnellement
officiellement ses relations avec l'otan
ce lundi mise à exécution d'une annonce
il y a près de deux semaines dans la
foulée du retrait des accréditations de
8 émissaire russe la russie qui réagira
au déploiement de missiles américains en
europe affirmations de vladimir poutine
tout à l'heure devant des représentants
du ministère russe de la défense la
correspondance à moscou de maylis
d'estrées le président russe a souligné
que l'intensité croissante des volets
rien de l'otan près des frontières de la
russie ainsi que l'apparition de navires
de l'alliance équipés de missiles en mer
baltique et en mer noire nécessité une
amélioration du système de défense
aérospatiale russe
nous savons vous et moi et nous savons
bien que certains de nos collègues
étrangers n'abandonnent pas leurs
tentatives de casser cette parité
stratégique y compris en déployant des
éléments d'une défense antimissile
global à proximité immédiate de nos
frontières et par
granit
nous ne pouvons ne pas remarquer ces
menaces pour la sécurité de la russie et
nous réagirons de manière appropriée
adéquate dans cette situation
actuellement comme vous le savez un
navire américain est entré en mer noire
nous pouvons le regarder à travers des
jumelles ou à travers le viseur des
systèmes de défense appropriée
le chef d'état a également évoqué la
menace que représente le déploiement de
missiles américains en europe
il existe également des plans américains
bien connue de déploiement de missiles à
moyenne portée en europe
ce qui constitue également un grand
danger et une menace pour nous
d'après via zimmer poutine le système de
défense russe améliorez devra détecter
les missiles balistiques et hypersonique
de tous types et pour aller détruire sur
toutes les trajectoires de vol le
président a également précisé que le
premier échantillon du nouveau système
de missiles s 500 devrait bientôt être
livrés à l'armée russe
dans l'actualité également la crainte
d'une cinquième vague en france qui se
fait de plus en plus grande épidémie
repart en croire les chiffres
et pendant ce temps est la campagne
vaccinale n'avance pas aussi vite
surtout chez les personnes âgées les
précisions en images avec adrien
frontenaud
[Musique]
pour le
bon
[Musique]
et
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
pierre tattevin épidémiologistes chef du
service des maladies infectieuses du chu
de rennes bonsoir bien maintenant merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france le nouveau des nouveaux cas qui
augmente d hospitalisation aussi
clairement est-ce qu'on doit s'inquiéter
aujourd'hui
je c'est vrai que ça augmente parce
qu'on était tombé vraiment très bas mais
ce qui peut rassurer c'est qu'on est
quand même à dix fois moins que ce qu'on
a vu au sommet des vagues précédentes en
terme d'incidence donc on est passé de
44 à 48 depuis cinquante-quatre pour
cent mille d'incidence donc ça vous
manque il faut renforcer les efforts il
faut certainement continuer à essayer de
donner lé troisième dose à ceux pour qui
c'est indiqué donc il ya du travail à
faire mais la situation ne ressentent
pas un début d'une quatrième vague quand
même ça ressemble plus à une petite
bosse qui justifie que l'on fasse mieux
mais en tout cas 55 départements dépasse
tout de même le seuil dallaire ont
trente deux départements la semaine
dernière vous comment vous expliquer
cette recrudescence
on arrive à un moment où les gens qui
ont été vaccinées il ya plus de six mois
sont moins bien protégés notamment chez
les personnes âgées parce qu'ils ont des
défenses immunitaires qui sont moins
qu'ils tiennent moins longtemps dans le
temps donc il faut faire cette troisième
dose il faut la faire en commençant par
ceux qui ont des systèmes immunitaires
les plus fragiles et je pense que ça
explique en partie pourquoi ça remonte
un petit peu donc il faut qu'on
s'applique là dessus alors la
vaccination justement en plus de 76% la
population totale en rappelant que
antico vie n'est pas administré aux
moins de 12 ans ça ne suffit pas pour
l'immunité en tout cas pas suffisamment
dans le temps
ça a suffi pour nous permettre en france
métropolitaine d'avoir quasiment pas de
vagues au moment de l'automne alors que
et de l'été alors que dans des
départements outre-mer qui était pas
bien vacciné sec est catastrophique faut
pas voir les choses de manière trop
négative on a on a sauvé beaucoup de
monde et on a évité mais probablement
une nouvelle
situation catastrophique cet été au
début de l'automne c'est pas si mal 75 %
de gens ayant reçu deux doses il faut
jusqu'au 6 mai le j'aimerais le bon
n'est pas assez haut mais il est bon en
revanche impératif d'accélérer
d'accélérer le pas sur on le disait les
personnes âgées ça pose encore problème
il n'y a pas cette troisième dose
nécessaire
bah oui c'est sûr que c'est là qu'il
faut qu'on fasse le plus d'efforts parce
qu'à la fois ils sont parfois difficiles
à atteindre tous les efforts pour aller
même les vacciner à domicile et qu'en
plus c'est eux qui perdent la protection
le plus vite parce que les anticorps les
globules blancs fonctionne moins bien 80
ans que quand on en avant pour les
autres ça tient encore les personnes qui
ont déjà été
vaccinées
donc pas les personnes âgées tout le
reste de la population y compris
d'ailleurs les plus de 12 ans pour le
moment pas de troisième dose nécessaire
en vue
ça va sûrement être nécessaire mais ce
sera nécessaire - moins vite que pour
les autres la plupart des gens entre 20
et 50 ans qui ont été vaccinés comme il
n'était pas priori charisme était plutôt
vacciner entre mars et juillet cela sous
encore bien protégé pour les mois qui
viennent c'est pour ça qu'il s'est pas
dans les priorités actuellement sauf
maladie qui les rend plus fragiles
aujourd'hui on le voyait
peut-être une baisse des gestes
barrières on se fait davantage la bise
on fait plus trop attention est ce que
ça inquiète le médecin que vous êtes ont
finalement ma foi le vaccin suffit
il suffit visiblement pas puisqu'on voit
quand même de temps en temps des
vaccinés qui attrapent la maladie c'est
pas une protection de 100% mais je ne
suis je trouve pas qu'on se relance
relâche tant que ça sur les mesures
barrières quand on se promène dans la
rue on voit que les gens continuaient à
mettre le masque notamment en intérieur
je pense on est des humains quoi on ne
peut pas fonctionner comme des machines
tout le temps et je trouve que
globalement les français sont quand même
beaucoup d'efforts depuis un an et demi
vous travaillez en ch ur on a parlé ces
derniers temps des vins pension de lits
fermés dans les hôpitaux vous le voulez
le constater aujourd'hui comment vous
vous l'expliqué pierre tattevin
on a eu des lits fermés au cours des
dernières années ça a été un mouvement
qui elle nous a pas aidés même pour la
prise en charge d autres maladies mais
plus récemment nous on est restés à
notre niveau de lit habituel je crois
que c'est surtout en ile de france où
ils ont été obligés de fermer des lits
par mots de personnel et où la situation
est plus compliquée merci en tout cas
certainement épidémiologie chef du
service des maladies infectieuses du chu
de rennes d'avoir été avec nous nous
avoir un petit peu rassuré tout de même
merci à vous merci d'arrêter en direct
sur rt france et jean castex lui a été
interpellé par les présidents
socialistes de 15 départements dans une
lettre adressée au premier ministre il
proteste contre le fait de rendre
éligibles au rsa les salariés suspendu
faute de schéma vaccinal complet ces
élus pointent du doigt le manque de
concertation sur le sujet le
gouvernement de son côté reste
inflexible et rappelle que toute
personne sans ressource peut prétendre à
la solidarité nationale
près de 600 jours après leur fermeture
les frontières de l'australie ont
rouvertes à scènes de joie et de
retrouvailles pour certains dans les
aéroports alors que des dizaines de
milliers d'australiens vivent à
l'étranger incapable de rejoindre leur
pays natal pendant 19 mois pour les
vacciner la quarantaine à l'arrivée sur
le territoire est finie elle aussi grâce
d'ailleurs
scènes de liesse à l'aéroport de sydney
c'est le grand jour pour les nombreuses
familles qui n'ont pu voir leurs proches
depuis 18 mois les ressortissants
australiens peuvent enfin revenir ou
quitter le pays sans autorisation
particulière
c'est énorme nous avons été bloqués à
l'étranger nous avons enfin cette chance
de revenir c'est juste incroyable
donc nous sommes un peu dépassée
impatient de voir nos familles ça va
être incroyable
pouvoir rentrer chez soi sans devoir
passer par la quarantaine est énorme il
y a beaucoup de gens sur ce vol qui ont
des proches qui vont mourir ou des gens
qui sont morts cette semaine donc
descendre de l'avion est allé les voir
tout de suite est assez incroyable
fantastique c'est génial d'être de
retour je vais voir mon mari dans deux
minutes et mes chiens je suis très
excité la réouverture des frontières un
choix conforté par le fort taux de
vaccination près de 80 % d'adultes sont
entièrement vacciner pour rappel le pays
avait instauré les restrictions les plus
sévères au monde depuis le 20 mars 2020
600 jours durant lesquels de nombreux
vols internationaux sont restés bloqués
sur le tarmac et où bon nombre de
familles ont été séparées sur plusieurs
continents ils seraient environ 47
milles encore bloqués à l'étranger
souhaitant rentrer en australie selon le
ministère des affaires étrangères
nombreux également sont les
ressortissants étrangers à attendre de
pouvoir rentrer dans leur pays
nous sommes arrivés mi janvier 2020 mon
mari avait un contrat de six mois et
nous ne rentrons que maintenant mais je
ne pouvais pas imaginer un meilleur
endroit dans le monde pour être bloquée
durant ces 22 mois
pour le retour des résidents vacciner
les quarantaines seront imposées ou pas
en fonction du pays d'arrivée par
exemple si sidney a supprimé la
quarantaine d'autres états où la
vaccination est encore trop faible
impose toujours une quarantaine
obligatoire et coûteuse de 14 jours dans
un hôtel pour les travailleurs qualifiés
et les étudiants internationaux qui
souhaitent entrer dans le pays les
frontières seront de nouveau ouvertes
d'ici la fin de l'année
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
notre rubrique qu'en pensent les
français nous irons à la rencontre d'un
chasseur la chasse qui alimente le débat
politique à six mois de la
présidentielle après deux accidents de
chasse les derniers jours faut-il
l'interdire le week-end nous en
débattrons
[Musique]
la violence peut déstabiliser la société
trop de sécurité de mettre en danger nos
libertés
[Musique]
on nous avait annoncé des faillites en
cascade et une catastrophe économique la
reprise économique est elle finalement
plus dynamique que prévu le taux de
faillite il a diminué pourquoi tout
simplement parce que on a subventionné
les entreprises et cela depuis le départ
c'est à dire qu'on a remplacé du chiffre
d'affaires par de la dette on peut dire
qu'à la fin de l'année dernière
l'essentiel de la croissance il vise
pour cette année était déjà fait on peut
afficher des chiffres qu'il paraisse
mirobolant mais qui en fait sont très
loin de la réalité et des flux
économiques réels maintenant moi ce que
j'attends c'est la fin réelle des aides
de l'état et la fin réelle des aides de
l'état risque d'être un petit peu plus
compliqué l'économie va tellement bien
que pour faire face aux chocs redouter
de l'impact de la hausse du prix du
pétrole ou des carburants on revient
vite à la charge avec un chèque de 100
euros c'est peut-être que quand même il
ya des fragilités dont on nous parle pas
tout à fait mais qui inquiètent
bougrement
[Musique]
et
la communication des modèles mâcon au
prêt à des jeunes via twitter instagram
kicked off est-ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant en poule et où ça n'a
plus rien depuis c'est pour se
rapprocher des jeunes mais parce qu'ils
sont beaucoup trop déconnecté de la
sphère politique il pense que ça va
ramener les jeunes à la politique dont
il se désintéresserait en lieu et place
de politiser les jeunes ça dépolitise la
politique pendant la rendant encore plus
on est justement c'est une nouvelle
forme de communication assez verticale
utiliser des influenceurs pour moissac
hommes politiques personnelles est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est vraiment
nouveau d'utiliser des célébrités pour
faire de la propagande politique on s'en
fiche nous on veut quelqu'un qui dirige
la france comme si son travail en notre
nom pour nous aider dans notre intérêt à
tous
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté vous remercie de m'avoir
invité
[Musique]
au coeur des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour qui décèdent de maladies
cardio cérébrovasculaires c'est à dire
ses choeurs cerveau artarit c'est une
véritable urgence épidémiologique parce
que c'est l'hygiène de vie qui a fait
celui des maladies cardiovasculaires des
femmes première cause de mortalité six
fois plus que le cancer du sein par
exemple il ya toujours trois fois plus
importante chez les hommes que chez les
femmes ce qui nous alertent nous c'est
la progression du nombre de femmes
jeunes hospitalisés pour infarctus vous
expliquez que ça n'arrive pas par hasard
c'est une maladie qui est évitable dans
huit cas sur dix est évitable ça veut
dire que l'hygiène de vie c'est notre
facteur de risque numéro un on a plutôt
un système de soins qui était accès
fléché sur le traitement de la maladie
de son diagnostic et le traitement et
non pas sur la prévention et on est dans
un système très curatif 1 c'est
essentiel d'avoir l'information pour pas
subir
[Musique]
faux
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp
les pions prennent la place des rois
de films stratégies peuvent porter des
résultats inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis les chômeurs et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
il est 21h merci non loin de penser
deuxième partie d'émission au sommaire
faut-il interdire la chasse de week-end
c'est la question de notre face à face
ce soir et celle que l'on vous pose en
attendant toujours vos réactions sur le
conte télégramme verte et france un
sujet qui alimente le débat politique à
six mois de la présidentielle après de
nouveaux accidents de chasse et derniers
jours
et ce week-end deux personnes ont donc
été gravement blessée par des chasseurs
en france pour de nombreux acteurs de la
vie publique il est temps de mettre en
place une interdiction partielle de
cette activité au moins le temps du week
end ce soir nous donnons la parole à ces
chasseurs interpellé nous sommes allés à
la rencontre de l'un d'entre eux en
septembre dernier pour notre rubrique
qu'en pensent les français pour maxime
gombart leur mode de vie et la ruralité
sont incompris par les politiques un
reportage de metz qui se marrent deros
et lucas léger je me trouve à la mode
brebières sur le terrain du centre de
formation de la fédération
départementale des chasseurs de la somme
en compagnie de maxime gombart chasseur
depuis 29 ans bonjour monsieur lombard
je suppose que donc la chasse ça fait
partie de votre vie depuis toujours la
chasse effectivement ça fait partie de
ma vie comme vous l'avez dit 29 ans donc
de permis et puis avant il ya aussi
toutes ces années où je ne chassait pas
mais j'accompagnais mon père mon grand
père sur le terrain donc on va dire plus
de 40 ans d'expérience de terrain et de
gestion de des milieux nous qui avons
été élevés dans le monde rural on a été
élevé au milieu des desmarais au milieu
des forêts au milieu des plaines avec
comme activité la chasse mais y'a pas
que la chasse aussi la pêche et toute la
gestion qui va autour au reproche
souvent les détracteurs de la jasse
disent qu'il ya des accidents de chasse
qu'il ya des accidents mortels y en a
tous les ans effectivement est ce que
vous vous pensez que c'est quelque chose
qui sur lequel on peut encore travailler
on peut toujours travailler sur la
sécurité que ce soit la chasse ou sur la
route ou n'importe où la sécurité on
travaille dessus vous l'avais dit il ya
eu des accidents mortels y en a eu cinq
l'an dernier c'est toujours 5 de trop et
même un ce sera toujours un accident de
trop donc on va aller jeter un oeil aux
au siège de la fédération et bien
allons-y ces mots sont la maison
signature
vous avez manifestée récemment c'est
quand même extrêmement rare de voir des
chasseurs dans la rue
oui effectivement c'est rare de voir des
chasseurs dans la rue ça prouve
effectivement que le ras-le-bol est là
la ruralité est attaqué de toutes parts
aujourd'hui il ya eu le monde agricole
qui s'est fait attaquer la chasse la
pêche
demain ça va être le monde de
l'équitation on voit bien que toutes les
activités de nature ou qui tourne autour
de l'animal sont attaqués alors on est
dans la rue aujourd'hui on l'a été en 89
on a été en 98 et s'il faut y retourner
on y retournera pour faire voir aux gens
que on est là qu'on existe qu'on n'est
pas 10 % de la population dans la
ruralité c'est un tout c'est un ensemble
c'est un mode de vie c'est une culture
quand j'étais à la manifestation j'ai
quand même vu qu'ils avaient des
discours contre les écolos non c'est pas
une critique contre l'écologie puisque
nous sommes les premiers écologistes de
france non c'est une critique contre
l'escroc logis oui mais pas contre
l'écologie l'écologie nous on en fait
tous les jours on gère les milieux on
gère les espèces on essaye de trouver
l'équilibré agro sylvo cynégétique mais
voilà on ne peut pas faire ça sans être
un minimum écologue nous sommes tous des
écologues alors faut pas confondre
écologistes et anti chasse c'est
complètement différent nous sommes des
écologistes et il ya les anti chasse en
face de nous
je vais vous présenter maintenant le
directeur de la fédération de chasse de
la somme tirée delfosse qui est
également aussi un écrivain célèbre au
niveau national il ya un courant qui
n'est pas nouveau mais qui s'est
beaucoup développée ces dernières années
qui ne supportent plus cet acte de
chasse la société accepte plus l'image
de la mort or la mort ça fait partie de
la vie ou un projet des gamins ont sorti
un lapin à clapiers on le tue et on
dépose et on ne mangeait de dimanche
c'était tout à fait normal maintenant
simple fait d'avoir un chien en laisse
ça va être considérée comme une attaque
sur l'animal parce que chez elle en
laisse ou il ya des canards qui sont
attachées par la patte quand on va la
hutte je pense qu'on marche sur la tête
et à une évolution
porté par une minorité qui n'est certes
pas représentatif mais qui quand même
commence à nous gonfler sérieusement
quand on en a ras-le-bol
revenons aux huttes brûlé qu'on trouve
nos voitures tags et qu'on se fasse
insulter si je vous suis c'est devenu
presque à la mode de dire du mal des
chasseurs bien sûr on peut dire du mal
des chasseurs sans problème à les
insulter n'importe qui dans un sens de
mort ça va faire autre chose quoi merci
beaucoup pour votre témoignage
merci
qu'est ce que vous espérez du débat de
l'élection présidentielle est ce que
vous voudriez que cette question soit
abordée oui tout à fait il faut qu'on
prenne de plus en plus
position pour la protection de
l'environnement pour la biodiversité ça
c'est un fait il faut
il faut de surcroît que cette ruralité
soit mise en avant soit gérée et il nous
faut il faut absolument sortir la chasse
du ministère de l'environnement pour
créer absolument un ministère de la
ruralité qui va gérer les territoires
qui va gérer la faune sauvage qui va
gérer les mines et yonne et voilà donc
un affrontement idéologique entre deux
camps ce soir dans le cadre de la
campagne présidentielle faut-il
interdire la chasse le week-end comme le
demande le candidat d'europe écologie
les verts yannick jadot ou au contraire
faut-il créer un grand ministère de la
ruralité indépendant de l'environnement
comme le demandent les chasseurs c'est
l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler ce soir es10
puijalon président du mouvement de la
ruralité bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur ce plateau pour nous
accompagner philippe bourrier achi
conseiller régional europe écologie en
ile-de-france bonsoir philippe hab
riachi merci d'être avec nous un mot
tout d'abord à je vous ai vu voilà un
petit peu accusé le coup parce que c'est
vrai que il mâche pas ses mots ce
chasseur écologistes et anti chasse est
différent il parle d' escroc logis ou
qu'est ce que vous répondez et surtout
qu'est ce qu'il entend par là surtout à
lui qu'il faut poser les questions que
si l'otan par là en tout cas moi ce que
je peux dire sur les propos on a entendu
évidemment on condamne nous les
écologistes toute forme de violence et
je les invite à regarder les vidéos de
ses amis les chasseurs comment ils
maltraitent les militants écologistes
qui essaye de faire prendre conscience
et qui demandent juste à pouvoir
bénéficier de la nature comme tout le
monde et se balader en sécurité est lié
au fait jalons escrocs l'ogive aux
employeurs employés ce thème également
vous étiez d'accord avec toutes les
critiques assénées
ce témoin aux écologistes pour la partie
oui évidemment sur la partie gestion des
territoires
vie sociétale dans la ruralité et mme
après la partie écologie ou escroc logis
lé lé limite entre guillemets parce que
parfois on le voit bien l'écologie
politique a besoin d'exister et de faire
un peu de trash et de remuer les choses
je pense que yannick jadot et en 2016
expliqué que son grand père était
chasseur qu'il comprenait la chasse même
s'il ya des situations où des espèces
qui comprenait pas qu'on chasse ou tel
type de mode de chasse mais il avait un
discours beaucoup plus souple qui ne l'a
aujourd'hui alors je pense
qu'aujourd'hui évidemment le sujet
devient très prégnant il ya le parti
animalistes il ya reçu mélenchon qui
fait de la surenchère et donc tout le
monde fait de la surenchère
dans ce canton se présenter à la
présidence de la république on essaie
plutôt de rassembler les français
d'avoir un discours rassembleur dit m
les règles mais voilà faire de la
ségrégation expliqué que les chasseurs
ne pas leur place le week-end pendant
les vacances scolaires je trouve ça
ridicule parce que moi je suis née la
naturalité j'adore les gens qui viennent
en vacances chez nous on discute et puis
il ya des règles à mettre en place alors
permettez moi juste de dire quand même
j'ai une pensée pour les deux personnes
blessées que je lance un coup de gueule
aussi aux chasseurs en france tu leur
demande de faire très très attention de
privilégier la sécurité de faire
toujours attention loin alors à leurs
tirs mais il faut savoir aussi les
choses je me dire notre ami le
représentant de paul que j'y vais c'est
que c'est quand même le monde de
l'écologie qui a demandé aux chasseurs
d'abandonner un certainement de tir de
passer avec des armes très puissante la
chasse en quelques années à faire un
effort considérable c'est comme si vous
demandiez aux automobilistes de rouler
avec 600 chevaux sous le capot on a eu
des armes très puissant qu'il a fallu
faire baisser les accidents on est
arrivé aujourd'hui dix accidents de trop
en mai voilà c'est une chose qui est
assez compliquée à gérer il ya beaucoup
de grands gibiers il faut assurer ce set
c'est probablement dans des conditions
très particulières mais beaucoup de
routes et des habitations il ya des
règles qui sont draconiennes mais encore
une fois de plus s'il justifie rien il
faut zéro accident il faut toujours
penser que quand on a une arme à la main
on doit savoir ce que l'on fait comme on
le fait et quitte à ne pas tirer il faut
être dans sécurité donc pas attention à
ces deux personnes toujours deux
personnes de trop mais voilà je pense
que les gens peuvent vivre parfaitement
ne renonce il ya aujourd'hui sur les
territoires la possibilité de se
retrouver dans la nature cavaliers
randonneurs
naturaliste photographe chasseurs
évidemment que ça enfin le monde ici
heureusement je veux dire un million de
pratiquants vous savez où 974 personnes
renversées sur les pains des cyclistes
est ce qu'on va interdire le week-end la
voiture pendant les vacances je pense
pas encore une fois de plus même les
trottinettes aujourd'hui on voit qu'il
ya des gens qui trottinait sur la route
mais on va essayer de mettre du dvd
bande de fluo faire monter la sécurité
pour le moins d'accidents possible parce
que des jeunes qui se sont renversés
c'est toujours désagréable
donc voilà le vivre ensemble il faut
faire monter la sécurité voilà c'est
notre rôle à tous à chacun et puis la
parole a fini beau gâchis ya quand même
effectivement c'est ce que dit notre ami
dipj à lyon qu'on a entendu aussi et
dans ce témoignage une forme le
sentiment d'une forme d'acharnement tout
ce qui touche à la nature
qu'est ce que vous répondez
à cela alors tout simplement on est
vraiment désolé si ils pensent qu'ils
sont acharnées mais nous les écologistes
nous aimons avant tout le vivant tous
les vivants et les animaux font partie
du corps des vivants on ne veut pas
embêter les salles les chasseurs sauf
monsieur a parlé de deux accidents quand
même leur interdire la chasse le
week-end et pendant les vacances
scolaires
il ya sept jours dans la semaine du
lundi au vendredi sans les cinq ça leur
laisse déjà pas mal de de plaisir et de
loisirs visiblement puisque c'est plutôt
un loisir le rappeler quelques chiffres
en deux entre 2019 et 2020 il ya eu 131
blessés et onze morts en 2020 2021
heureusement quelques vides il ya eu 80
blessées et sept morts alors on peut
parler d'accidents lorsque c'est une
fois et c'est spontané mais lorsque
c'est répétitif je ne veux pas aller
jusqu à outrager monsieur et ses amis
les chasseurs on peut considérer que là
il ya des homicides volontaires parce
que lorsqu'on met une arme entre les
mains j'ai entendu parler de prélèvement
lorsqu'on met une arme par destination
elle ôte la vie alors maintenant son
chasseur et son chien
d'autant plus de prendre cette
conscience et cette conscience
collective on a entendu parler que les
mentalités changent et ben ça tombe bien
c'était une phrase 200 m rousseau pour
dire les temps changent quand on parle
de prélèvement je voudrais rappeler
monsieur le président que 20 millions
d'animaux sont élevées à destination de
la chasse je voudrais entendre aussi
pourquoi les chasseurs ont besoin de
nourrir les sangliers et les cerfs pour
pouvoir donc puisque vous plus vous avez
nourri un peu mou ils vont se développer
et donc plus vous avez besoin de faire
des prélèvements je crois qu'il est
temps que maintenant que les usagers de
la nature les citoyens les femmes les
enfants puissent se promener et cueillir
des champignons sans se dire aujourd'hui
à un membre de notre famille va finir à
l'hôpital pour détresse vitale ou alors
à la moria alors c'est très attendu en
vain pour passer la parole pardonnez moi
eric fuyez puijalon je voudrais quand
même regarder ans et quelques messages
parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup tout au long
de la journée manifestement c'est un
débat là qui crée la passion toujours et
encore pour eric oui la forêt appartient
aussi aux promeneurs la quasi-totalité
des forêts sont privés en france autre
position non il ne faut pas interdire la
chasse le week-end c'est absurde la
chasse est indispensable c'est vrai que
on a toujours le sentiment qui est un
peu deux camps quand on parle de ce
débat sur les chasseurs pourquoi autant
de passion il dit puijalon parce que je
pense que
l'écologie politique est neuf et un
effet une tête de turc les chasseurs et
ont fait monter une sorte de haine et
les gens ont besoin de se défouler
aujourd'hui donc c'est facile d'agresser
un chasseur comme un agriculteur
aujourd'hui malheureusement les éleveurs
on semble aujourd'hui à gressier des
agriculteurs sur leur tracteur prennent
la découpe fut dès coups de poing dans
la figure parce qu'ils sont en train de
traiter leurs vignes par exemple c'est
aujourd'hui une maladie qui a été mis en
place par les gens de l'écologie en
métro montrant du doigt des gens qui ne
méritent pas quand on sauve des vies
parce que on appuie réguler les
sangliers en bordure d'autoroute ou de
route et qu'on sait très bien qu'il ya
des accidents mon alter mortel avec les
grands gibiers quand on fait du travail
pour réguler pour empêcher qu'il ya des
dégâts à l'école et les agriculteurs ne
devraient plus on vient pas voir si le
chasseur fait son bourreau et qu'il est
là pour réguler les grands gibiers mais
non on est en train de l'agresser en
disant on protège le vivant je suppose
que si on continue comme le dit monsieur
et certaines de ses amies qui sont en
train de vouloir protéger la punaise de
lit mais demain on va pouvoir toucher
une source qu'un moustique quoi je veux
dire si ça devient tout et n'importe
quoi le vidéo le bo on est important
mais on ne peut pas non plus considérer
que l'homme ne fait pas partie du bilan
merci merci merci justement de
considérer non vous pousser à
l'extrême et j'entends vous êtes en
train de défendre votre paroisse et evo
vos soutiens et ceux de votre parti
politique on a vu d'ailleurs votre vidéo
des jeux où vous en guirlandes et vos
collègues parce qu'il n'était pas assez
présent et manifestations et ça je peux
l'entendre qui a un désamour ou d
intéressement de de vos clients ou de
vos patients ou de vos collègues vu
l'âge élevé de ceux et celles qui
pratiquent ce n'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est la fédération des chasseurs
monsieur on veut pas vous déranger on
veut pas vous embêter mais pouvez-vous
comprendre qu'il faut que nous
partagions un espace commun que le
bien-être des gens qui se promène en
forêt qui prennent ce grand bol d'air ce
grand antidépresseurs gratuit et naturel
vous pouvez l'entendre ça vous savez que
celui qui a été grièvement blessé il est
entre la vie et la mort et moi je veux
avoir une pensée pour lui et pour sa
famille qui doivent être dans tous leurs
états ils étaient ils étaient en voiture
sur la quatre voies entre rennes et
nantes
il n'était pas dans la forêt donc là on
peut plus les accidents il faut
réellement ensemble qu'ensemble on
s'assoit à la tout autour d'une table
que vous discutiez avec yannick jadot au
lieu de discuter avec ayman macro qui
vous fait des belles courbes est pour
avoir vous voix pour les élections
discuter que les écologistes discuter
que l'association one voice discuter
avec l 214 discuter si schipper discuter
si vous voulez pas parler avec nous
parler avec les associations moi je vous
invite à discuter weiss et vous verrez
peut-être que vous changerez d'avis
plein de gens intelligents mais à
condition qu'ils aient pas d'intégrisme
et de malhonnêteté quand on est ouverts
vers les autres et c'est tout en
interdisant aux vêtements moi je crois
que du débat de du respect de chacun on
arrive toujours à grandir les choses
sauf qu'en réalité on a très bien vu
qu'aujourd'hui les gens attise les ailes
il ya des groupuscules aujourd'hui qui
sont là depuis très longtemps le savez
très bien fais comme soul nous
condamnons nous condamnons glisse avait
tout le soutien et toute forme de
violence quelle qu'elle est lorsque
votre discours et que vous vouliez ou
non quand et yannick janaudy jadot dit
il va falloir interdire la chasse
comique end et pendant les vacances
scolaires vous stigmatisez et donc vous
rajoutez une couche aux gens qui se
permettent aujourd'hui d'agresser de
venir ici j'ai un côté monsieur le maire
si dense et nous voulons juste protéger
une famille il faut s'il faut partager
cet espace nous proposons de les
partager je voulais pas voulez vous le
voulez assister % en es ce que je dis
que j'ai dit autre chose
décidément c'est cette question de la
chasse et dans toutes les campagnes
présidentielle et ça ne va pas manquer
cette fois ci encore je vous propose
justement d'écouté yannick jadot
la justice française cas
systématiquement les décrets du
gouvernement sur la chasse des animaux
protégés emmanuel macron est un
président sous influence du lobby de la
chasse j'interdirais la chasse le
week-end et pendant les vacances
scolaires
emmanuel macron sous influence du lobby
de la chasse et des appuis jalons déjà
monsieur genou il dit des bêtises de
jijel foison non on ne chasse pas les
espèces protégées canton par les
alouettes période c'est une espèce
chasse au fusil en l'occurrence et
chasses traditionnelles ont été
interdites sur une pratique de chasse au
filet ancestrale mais en aucune manière
ce sont des espèces protégées on a
encore des choses qui sont des contre
vérités sur le fait que que monsieur
macron défendre les chasseurs en
particulier oui il en a fait et il en a
fait certaines certaines faveurs entre
guillemets sur le permis de chasser mais
il sait aussi l'utilité
de par me dis là c'est sûr sur le permis
national monsieur mais vous savez comme
une chambre et le permis national la
chasse populaire que l'on pratique dans
le sud de la france ou même dans toute
la france ce sont d'abord des salariés
des voiliers qui prennent pas un permis
national donc permis à rester au même
prix que j'espère qu'on fait là
référence est-ce que vous avez défendu
cette chasse aux rides qui est la chasse
à glu pour mémo la nature et et grün
diriger
ce qu'ils appellent leurs congénères
pour que vous puissiez d'étirer à 5,10 m
enfin franchement ce sont des méthodes
philippe ouriachi pour ce qu est ce que
vous êtes d'accord
il est chasseur nous dit yannick jadot
ce serait pas le premier ni le dernier
puisque on dit tout le temps que ce
lobby est très puissant est ce que c'est
vous l'avez constaté vous on l'a vu très
puissant et très violent je vous invite
à regarder à nouveau ne serait ce que
les vidéos de l'a20 qui manifestent
contre les chasses à courre et comment
sont reçus les militants écologistes et
est donc tous les présidents le font de
manière rectorat mais aussi ont peur
c'est que vous avez un million de
personnes armées de fusils vous n'avez
pas trop envie de vous frotter à alors
les écologistes c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup plus simple d'aller leur taper
dessus parce qu'ils sont pacifistes et
qui vous reçoivent avec des fleurs et
des bonbons vous inversez les rôles la
chasse est une activité légale le délit
d'entravé et devrait être beaucoup plus
mises en place aujourd'hui et plus
responsable ce s'habituerait des
affrontements et des risques de
débordements on n'est pas là en fait je
ne sais pas si vous concevez que un
citoyen un groupe de citoyens peut aller
demain dans une boucherie charcuterie
interdit à un boucher charcutier de
travail et un chasseur de pratiquer un
pêcheur de pratiquer sous l'égide qu'il
pense que lui et pas d'accord ça devient
de l'anarchie moi je respecte et les
agglos des sons de mada carte ici sinon
nouvelle monsieur le président monsieur
décisionnel monsieur vous pression et
pas vous même vous je vais dire monsieur
le président vous m'avez dit que vous
aimiez le vivent tous les vivants je
suppose que vous devez aimer les animaux
monsieur le président quel effet que ça
fait d'être une proie inoffensif avec
une meute de chiens et de chats soeur je
parle essentiellement de la chasse à
courre le stress que ces animaux vivent
avant d'arriver à la donner à la
souffrance monsieur le président un peu
de gêne à ce prix c'est le fait sourire
sur sur le sujet vous avez failli devant
les loups que vous êtes en train de
remettre en place le pays qui sont en
train de chasser en meute sur des
troupeaux de moutons mais aussi sur de
grands gibiers et là vous trouvez le
rayon sauvagement de nature tellement
beau que vous voyez pas de souffrance
vous voyez même pas la souffrance des
éleveurs et vous venez critiquer
quelqu'un qui pratique une chasse à
courre sur un cirque à toutes ces choses
est de toute manière qui ne reproduit
que l'activité naturelle qui se fait
qu'avec les grands prédateurs mais vous
surtout l'homme de l'intégrale veut
pousser
au moins vite et l'homme est comme un
grand entraîneur qui a besoin de la
chasse à courre est on est on sait tout
le business qui a autour de la chasse
est lourd pour un loisir et pour un
plaisir aussi morbide zombies vous avez
une vision et c'est votre choix
permettez-nous de la dénoncer de
dénoncer cette barbarie et de s'opposer
à ce départ est un futur présent la
public qui a le courage de se poser un
fugueur précédent la future prison de la
république qui s'opposent à cette forme
de barbarie de la surenchère pour
essayer de pour remonter un peu dans les
sondages le candidat qui a proposé
d'abolir totalement la chasse s'il avait
voulu faire de la surenchère il serait
monté un cran au dessus un autre
candidat toujours pas des devins à
moitié déclaré on va dire je vous
propose d'écouter eric zemmour ce qu'ils
en pensent
ce sont des bobos des villes qui font la
morale aux français deschamps les
attaques répétées des écologistes contre
la chasse est d'abord l'expression de
leur mépris pour la france et ses
traditions et enfin bouriaud si elle est
importante enfin pas importante non
intéressante cette cette phrase parce
que ça montre cette espèce vollard de de
la france séparé en deux deux camps
qu'est ce que vous répondez à cette
analyse eric zemmour je réponds à
monsieur et moi j'étais en cure parce
que pendant deux jours j'ai pas entendu
parler de zemmour donc là ça me remet ça
me remet une piqûre je lui réponds que
80% des français veulent abolir la
chasse est donc pour un demi candidat
qu'il est aujourd'hui sans vouloir lui
manquer de respect il n'entend pas cette
majorité de français qui vient de
s'exprimer donc ça laisse présager de
mauvaises conditions si ce monsieur
arriver au plus grand de fonction
un mot de la fin
c'est absolument désolant il me semble
que je vois des partis politiques qui ne
sont là que pour pour courir après leurs
chapelles qui ne sont pas là pour
pratiquer le vivre ensemble est encore
une fois de plus - milieu rural que ce
soit un maire qui soient chasseurs un
docteur on a toutes les classes de la
société qui lui qui pratique cette belle
passion et croyez bien que les gens qui
viennent de la ville quand ils viennent
auprès des gens qui sont chasseurs les
apprécie et qui revoit un peu les
considérations que font par vos méthodes
et puis parmi ses
500 présidence admet très agréable dé
lever 20 millions d'oiseaux d'ouvrir la
cage de les laisser s'envolèrent on
serait dans le sketch des inconnus avec
la galinette cendrée mais vous avez de
drôles de drôles de pratiques
je vous dirai pourquoi c'est utile parce
que c'est un pêche de de prélever d'un
certain là certaines biodiversité
certains lâché 2,2 faisant évite de aux
jeunes de prendre des perdrix ou autre
chose c'est quand même les mêmes
prélèvements qui est fait comme si vous
preniez un public vous achetez une assez
pas finalement vous les élever si
monsieur le président 20 millions
d'animaux disent qu'il faut de nourrir
et pour ça fait plaisir or une pratique
de quelques personnes que vous avez
invité d'ailleurs les bobos d'eric
zemmour à venir chasser ou bien
de brebis de vos deux vaches des cochons
élevés en france pour les tuer les
matchs et ma fille a rien de plus
naturel monsieur en plus nous les
pratiquants ne prend nous mêmes et des
foires les offres des fonds les consoles
nous mêmes c'est quelque chose
d'agréable on joue à 8000 agréable et
c'est ce fait agréable aller directement
au supermarché ou à la boucherie ou ou
chez le voilà y ait acheté votre votre
mail pour le déguster avec vos amis on
assume et pas moi j'assume mon rôle de
chasseur et de prédateur je prends mon
gibier jeu le consomment et je n'ai fait
qu'un geste naturel vous vous faites
l'amour par procuration et encore vous
n'êtes pas dans les esprits mais ceux
qui considèrent qu'il faut plus manger
de viande et d'élevage de magie que
l'avenir de cellulaires jeu mais
j'espère que pour nous ce n'est pas le
cas et que vous considérez que l'élevage
en france est quelque chose d'important
merci en tout cas à tous les deux dia
plus à l'onf il est pas bon gâchis on
termine sur ce message d'un
téléspectateur pascal du vilain ma
dernière non promenade en forêt qui fut
en semaine on m'a vivement conseillé de
porter un gilet jaune
peut-être est-ce également la meilleure
solution en week-end voilà c'était la
conclusion et puis avant que vous vous
quittez un je voudrais vous lancer cet
appel à témoigner vous qui vous
regardent et qui regarde rt france qui
est membre de votre famille ou avait été
victime d'un accident de chasse écrivez
donc à l'adresse qui s'affiche sur votre
écran qu'en pensent les français qu plf
@ rt tv.fr et si vous avez des histoires
des témoignages à nous raconter pas que
sur la chasse d'ailleurs sur vos
difficultés à payer les factures ou
encore l'impact que le comité a eu sur
votre vie ces dernières années cette
adresse et pour vous on vous répondra et
surtout vous pourriez interpeller nos
invités lors de débats comme ce soir
merci d'avoir suivi cette émission on se
retrouve demain 20h pour un nouveau
numéro en attendant l'actualité continue
toute la soirée sur rtl france
[Musique]
avec nous antoine perrut de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes cio comme on disait
dans les grandes entreprises
multinationales de saint gobain russie
ukraine on a beaucoup dit que bon
l'ouest et caïcos l'eau mais que l'est
et paul bert moi je suis convaincue at
et personnel que il faut réduire les
émissions de carbone sur la planète
entière donc les plus observés il faut
réduire les émissions de carbone dans
les pays en développement sur partout
partout vous avez construit des vignes
décarbonés vos des usines où on aimait
rire